( intro music )
Daniel: This is a bat that feeds
exclusively on blood
as the name implies.
And the way that
that bat feeds is
to make a razor sharp incision
into the animal that
it is feeding on and
then it uses a specially grooved
tongue to lap up blood.
That's not it,
because these bats
also have anti-coagulants
in their saliva
which keep that blood flowing
and after they finish eating,
they can just hop up into air
which is really
unusual for a bat
most have to climb
up onto something.
So, all of these traits
make bats incredibly
good transmitters
of rabies virus.
Rabies has been described
in ancient Chinese and Arabic
texts as an incurable wound
resulting from the bite
of a rabid animal.
That incurable part of
rabies is still true.
We still don't have a
treatment for people
once they start to
show signs of rabies.
Even by the most rudimentary
standards that we have now
one person still dies of the
disease every 15 minutes
and another 300 are exposed.
We are talking about
50,000-60,000 people
dying every year.
The natural response of the
people that are affected by this
is to kill bats.
The state sanctioned
way of killing bats
is using a poison
called vampiricide.
Where essentially a poison is
mixed together with Vaseline
and that's spread on
the back of a bat.
They release that one, it
flies back to its roost.
And the other ones groom it off,
ingest the poison and die.
Sounds straightforward enough.
Unfortunately, there's
not really much evidence
that it's doing anything
to control rabies.
One of the first questions
that I wanted to ask was
why is it that this
conventional wisdom
that the only good
bat is a dead bat
isn't actually
doing its purpose.
So, one of the most, I think,
innovative and exciting ideas
we've had in the last,
really, six months
is whether we can
replace the poison
that's used in
the vampiricide
with an oral rabies vaccine.
In Peru, we're
in a spectacular
situation to be
able to try this.
We've recently detected that
there are actually
travelling waves of rabies
moving down different
valleys of the Andes.
So, you can actually
see this on the map
where the dark points are
the old rabies cases
the light points are the
new rabies cases.
And we see them in a
very step like manner
moving through these valleys.
That is powerful.
That allows us tell
farmers, "okay
you're going to
have rabies.
You don't have it now,
but you will in a month
you will in six months,
you will in a year."
That allows them to make
an informed decision
about vaccination.
Second, this is a
really powerful
experimental opportunity.
We can consider this valley and
there are several others like it
we can consider these as
experimental replicates.
Can we try vaccinating at
various stages in the valley
or across different valleys and
compare that with other
types of interventions.
And say what works,
what doesn't...
can we use science
to figure this out?